I bet your master
found you difficult at times, Anakin
never got to finish my training.
I walked away
just like I walked away from the city.
I started hearing whispers about Thrawn's
return as heir to the Empire.
Anakin spoke highly of you.
You were so young
when you survived the war.
I'm not here to discuss my past.
You has no power.
You never made things easy for me
as a Jedi.
Sometimes you have to make the decision
no one else can.
I'm counting on you to see this through
What happens when you try and threaten
or others
Power?
nice haircut
This is a new beginning
War is inevitable.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my new Ahsoka trailer.
Episodes are starting really soon.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs here.
Of course,
I'll be doing videos for everything,
so be sure to subscribe
to get all those episodes.
I'll do a giveaway during episode videos
to lot of Anakin Skywalker going on during
this really think that he's
going to show up in some sort of cameos.
Like Hayden Christensen supposedly
signed a contract that would allow him
to come back in multiple ways,
like come back as Darth Vader
earlier in the timeline,
but also come back as force goes.
And again, at some point,
maybe even more flashback scenes,
which are also completely different,
there are a lot of ways
to include him in the story.
It only makes sense that he would have
more cameos scenes during Ahsoka
because there's such a connection
between those two characters
I talked about in previous videos too.
Even Rian Johnson during The Last Jedi,
I was almost going to include Force
Ghost Anakin instead of Force
Ghost Yoda with the Luke scenes,
the only reason why he went for Yoda
instead of an Anakin
is because
Luke had a much more personal relationship
in the original trilogy with Yoda
than he did with his father.
but now that we're doing
deep dives on a Ahsoka's character
she had that same kind of relationship
with Anakin Skywalker.
So it only makes sense that he would
show up during her series in some way.
Hayden
Christensen has said for a long time, too,
he would love to come back
as much as possible,
just depending on whatever
the project winds up being,
even though they haven't said
a whole lot about what they might do
with Obi-Wan Kenobi Season two.
They might do it, they might not do it.
They're very non-committal about it.
there's a lot of you also asking
about the Knights of the Old Republic
Easter eggs in this, too, with the Jedi's
Star Maps, an artifact
that was left behind
by the ancient record,
an infinite empire from the Knights
of the Old Republic series.
they were originally just
part of the legends canon,
but Andor actually recognized them again.
They brought them back into the canon.
the record and created the Star Maps
to be a self-sustaining technology
that was imbued with
and drew upon the dark side of the force.
These maps were fabricated to be monuments
to the glory of their empire.
Originally,
the maps were meant to show the locations
of their most powerful monuments,
like within the Knights
of the Old Republic series.
It was the Star Forge
because that was the big super weapon.
now it looks like Dave
Filoni is recognized in some more aspects
of the Knights
of the Old Republic story, too.
The Ahsoka series
a lot of you will remember
they already canonize
a lot of those characters as well, too.
Darth Revan probably the biggest one.
He was canonized during Star Wars.
The Rise of Skywalker on that Exegol
Sith planet.
There's a statue of Ram in there
during the Andor series, Tony Gilroy
brought them back into the canon
with this huge Easter egg
Luzon is trying to convince
and or to join their mission.
Early in the series,
He offers him the Kuwaiti signet,
which is meant to be a necklace
made from a kyber crystal.
The same crystals Jedi
and Sith use in their lightsabers,
based on the Ahsoka trailer footage.
They're implying that Thrawn's minion,
Morgan Elsbeth, that we met during
the Mandalorian,
has found a way to use the star maps
to locate Thrawn in the unknown regions,
in this might explain
why Thrawn and Morgan Elsbeth are working
with Balan School in Chinatown.
Because they need their Jedi
abilities, their force abilities.
They're not technically Jedi,
they're not Sith either,
They need people who can use the force
that can activate the star maps.
in Morgan Elsbeth has found a way
to use those maps to locate Thrawn
in the unknown regions.
And Thrawn has also learned
to use the star maps
to plot a course
through the unknown regions.
Lot of theories
about what Ezra Bridger was doing
while he was lost with Thrawn
in the unknown regions.
Maybe at some point
they started to work together.
We'll see about that.
the whole thing about Thrawn
is he's a very pragmatic character.
He doesn't hold grudges the same way
the Emperor held grudges, For instance,
even though he was fighting
against Ezra Bridger in All the Rebels
during the original Star Wars
rebel series.
If Ezra Bridger were the only person
who could help him escape
the unknown regions,
he would be happy to work with him.
a lot of the Ahsoka
series is re canonizing stuff
from the original Thrawn trilogy
and more about his backstory.
there's been a lot of new storylines
that they've introduced for his backstory
in the comics, as well as the novels,
the whole thing with Thrawn
is that as a member of the chiss race,
he had already possessed
partial maps of the unknown regions
that the Empire in the New Republic
didn't have access to.
So even though it seems like the star maps
are a big part of this and then plotting
a course through the unknown regions,
Their people already knew how to navigate.
Most of not everything,
but most of the unknown regions
this was the main reason
why the Emperor was interested
in Thrawn in the first place
right after the Clone Wars.
So any can Skywalker during the Clone Wars
accidentally discovers
Thrawn in the chest, and Thrawn
then offers his service to the Emperor,
as well as maps of the unknown regions
which he wanted in exchange
for the Emperor just leaving his people.
The ships alone,
This is part of the reason in present day
why he's also trying
to destroy the New Republic,
because he believes
he can manage the galaxy more efficiently
than the New Republic
or the Emperor himself.
Were he to resurrect and come back.
they kind of got into this whole concept
at the end of The Mandalorian Season
three with the Shadow Council.
The idea is that even though you have
all these different factions
within the Remnant Empire,
not all of them want the Empire back.
that was what Project
Necromancer was all about.
And it's being completed by Brendel Hux,
who's part of the forces on the Shadow
Council,
another group within the Remnant empire
that wind up becoming the first order
in the sequel movies.
His grandson is General Hux.
In the joke here, like the reference here
is that the actor who's playing
Brendel Hux is actually Donal Gleeson's
brother in real life.
so at this point in time
Thrawn doesn't care or like the Emperor,
he doesn't want him to be resurrected.
And not all the members of the Shadow
Council, even like Thrawn that much.
So it's sort of like evil
eating itself alive slowly, technically.
Thrawn is an evil, though,
like all the brand news story
that they introduced for his character
makes him
more of an anti-hero type of character.
He does a lot of terrible stuff,
but it's all in the name
of protecting his people, which is So
Thrawn is playing four dimensional chiss
with the other members of the Shadow
Council, which will price the reference
during Ahsoka at some point
and with the members of the New Republic,
which is trying to overthrow
It also seems like they're adapting
part of the Thrawn trilogy storyline
from the Dark Forces book.
That's the second book in the series
where he finds a new fleet of ships.
They give him a huge power upgrade
in the actual ability
to physically defeat
the New Republic during the Ahsoka series.
I think the change, though, is
that he'll have already found those ships
while he was missing
in the unknown regions
during the events of the original trilogy.
and we'll see all those
at the very end of the series
like he'll show up but we'll see him
full on with all this fleet of ships.
it seems that they're plotting the series
out this way in the first half of
the series will be Ahsoka before the events
of that Star Wars rebels ending scene.
But after the
events of the Mandalorian Season
two in the book of Boba Fett cameo seen
she starts learning about Thrawn's return
in the possibility of Ezra Bridger
coming back,
but she's mostly focused on finding Thrawn
and dealing with that threat.
then she goes to Hera
the New Republic with her concerns,
and here is the one who advises her
to get Sabine Ren's help
And they start to get into the story
of what happened between the two of them,
where there's some beef
between the two of them, mostly explaining
why Ahsoka took off at the end of rebels
and what she was doing.
And then was Sabine
Wren was doing this whole time.
I talked about that
in previous videos too.
Sabine stayed on Lothar
because she promised Ezra Bridges
that she would take care of the people
while Ezra was away.
She also kept Ezra's light saber, which is
why she's using it against Sinnott.
During the trailer footage.
Then they have almost
that exact same scene
from the end of Star Wars rebels,
but in live action.
And they take off
to actually find Thrawn in Ezra Bridger.
But the whole idea is that Sabine
Wren cares more about finding Ezra Bridger
than Thrawn, and Ahsoka cares more about
finding Thrawn than Ezra Bridger.
well, that's happening
during the first half of the series.
They set up the balance school
and hate characters, what they're doing
and why they're working with Thrawn,
even though they don't necessarily
care about the Empire coming back.
Like I said, I think it's
because they're the only force
sensitive people that will work with them
that can activate the star maps
because you need to be able
to wield the force
in order to use the star maps.
then the second half of the series
is focused more on what Thrawn
has actually been doing this whole time
and what really happened to Ezra Bridger.
So like the first half of the series
is kind of like
the first half of The Lord of the Rings
Fellowship of the Ring.
Then halfway through the season
the actual fellowship comes together
and then they head for Thrawn.
In the second half of the series.
there's actually a funny connection
between Ahsoka
and the Lord of the Rings series.
So back when Rise of Skywalker came out
and they had all the Jedi voices
speaking at the very end of the series
when they were defeating the Emperor
actually actually voiced Ahsoka
during the scene.
So a lot of people were like,
Wait a minute,
does that mean that Ahsoka is dead?
During the events of the sequel trilogy
and Dave Filoni posted this picture
of older Ahsoka looking
like she did at the end of Star Wars
rebels like she does in present day right
now, standing next to Gandalf with a joke
about people believing that
Gandalf had died because during the events
of the Lord of the Rings series, Gandalf
Winds up coming back to life.
so it was Dave Filoni basically
saying that Ahsoka was probably still alive
during the events of the sequel movies.
We'll just eventually find out
what she was doing and why she wasn't
in those movies that same way.
exact same phenomenon with the Grogu
character, like what was Grogu
doing during the sequel trilogy?
Because he would have been
about the same age that Yoda was
when Yoda became a Jedi master,
When the events of the sequel movies
are happening, But.
I think by the end of season one,
they're meant to actually find Thrawn
and find Ezra Bridger,
even though there might be some twist
behind that.
Because, for instance,
people are wondering what's going on
with this mystery inquisitor
who they're listing the name as Merrok.
Like he's being called Merrok,
but that's not a name from the canon.
they could either be a completely random
inquisitor, like just nobody at all.
Nobody's special.
Or it could actually be a character
that we know
is pretending as a different character
the weird thing about this
part of the timeline
is that the inquisitorious
did not survive the fall of the Empire
in Return of the Jedi
like they basically went away.
So why is this character
still being an inquisitor
during this part of the timeline?
as for The Mandalorian and Grogu
having any kind of cameo scenes
during the Sokka
series, it's always possible, like you
would expect them to cameo no one else.
They're basically bringing all
the characters back from Star Wars rebels.
So, like, that's why we saw Zeb
during the Mandalorian series.
I think that they'll focus more
on bringing those characters back that
they have not already brought back yet.
big reminder that the first two episodes
are dropping on the first day
and it'll be weekly after that.
They're eight episodes total,
just like The Mandalorian Series.
So of course I'll be doing videos
for everything.
leave all your big requests
or big questions in the comments below.
Or if you spotted any Easter eggs
or references in the trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video
or my other trailer videos,
we'll probably get another big trailer
in the next couple of weeks.
there's supposed to be a big Loki season
two trailer on Monday,
of course, will do a video for it.
If they wind up releasing it.
That'll be released
after the Ahsoka series is done.
click here for that
Loki Season two trailer Video.
Update the link
as soon as I post that and click here
for all my other Comic-Con trailer videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!